- All right, good evening everyone,
and thank you so much
for joining us today.
I'm joined with my colleague, Steve,
who'll be presenting later on,
and my name is Alicia Trent.
I'm humbled to say this is
my fifth year at re:Invent,
and it gets more and
more exciting every year.
With each presentation,
what we're finding is that we continue
to accelerate the growth of
agentic AI and generative AI.
In the past years, we've
talked about computer vision,
we've talked about bringing
IoT into machine learning
and leveraging it for
predictive maintenance.
We've talked about natural language.
This year we're gonna be
really focused on agentic AI,
and in this session specifically,
we're gonna be focused
on the fundamentals.
Many of the enterprises
that we're working with
are really excited about
generative AI and agentic AI.
However, there's also a
lot of concerns, right?
How do we manage these agents, right?
There's a lot of concern
around like agents running
around doing things
that you can't control,
and we'll really take a step back
and really focus on what you need to do
to be able to scale with confidence
and control within your organizations.
So we have a packed agenda,
and so we'll just get straight to it.
So with agentic AI,
we believe now is the time to get started.
We've been leveraging
agentic AI across Amazon,
across many different use
cases from the factory floor
to getting packages to your doorstep,
all the way through AWS
sales and marketing,
driving campaigns to help
support our customers.
We believe that this
evolution happens internally,
and we've already started to
do it within our organization.
So within each department,
we're all tasked
with leveraging agentic AI in the way
that we do business on a day-to-day basis.
So this transformation began
with the evolution of generative AI.
So originally, generative
AI was an intelligent way
to be able to respond to questions, right?
In a natural way, you can respond
to questions across complex issues.
With agentic AI, now you can
plan, reason, and take action.
And so that's the next evolution
that we're starting to move towards.
And it's really an exciting time
as we think about how it can
transform the way that you're working.
So in the past, agentic
AI or generative AI
would respond in a very simple way.
Now you could take that
and now become a very capable employee
to be able to help perform
tasks on your behalf.
So with Gartner, we've partnered with them
and what we found is that
customers are very excited about this.
And by 2028, about a third
of applications will be
leveraging agentic AI.
About 15% of work will
also be done autonomously,
leveraging generative AI.
So those may be shocking,
but the real push
and the real trend
behind this is to be able
to move from a reactive
to now a proactive way of working.
We're able to now take applications
where in the past you had to
just deal with the applications
that were built, in many cases
that are built from the masses, right?
So if you think about
your ERP, CRM system,
you had to massage it into
the way that you're working.
Now with the tools that we have today,
you think about the way that you work,
you create the agent to help support that,
you connect it to the data sources
that you're working within.
Like you connect it to the applications
that you need to do
these specific actions.
So think about your ERP, CRM systems.
These are in the past,
disconnected systems.
Now you can bring them to together
and be able to bring in
insights across these systems
and be able to communicate
via say, email or Slack.
Again, these were previously
disconnected systems,
but now you're able to work
seamlessly across each one
to be able to start to
accelerate the way you work.
And so the reason why now
is such a critical time
as we think about this,
is that with agentic AI,
what we're seeing is that it's
in the last five, six months.
We're seeing it double in
capabilities every six months.
Like in the past, it was a year,
two years where you're really
seeing this acceleration,
but we believe that this
will continue to double
every six to seven months
as we move forward.
The other area is price performance.
So we're seeing 100x
performance in mid-level
tier capabilities.
So in the past, you could perform
intelligent AI for basic capabilities,
now we're seeing more and
more complex activities
where you can start to
apply AI capabilities.
And the last piece is
that we believe that the
maturity of the enterprise
infrastructure is ready as well.
My colleague Steve will talk
more about the car guardrails
and controls that you can put
in place to be able to help
perform these actions
on a day-to-day basis.
So what does this mean?
So now that you have these tools,
what we're seeing is the evolution
where now you can change
your operating modes, right?
So in the past, you really had to be stuck
with the applications you're working in.
Now you can start to really
start to automate your redundant tasks,
you're able to bring in data
across many different systems
and make more targeted responses.
So think about bringing
in SharePoint information,
information on your desktop,
as well as your structured
databases across Snowflake,
Databricks, et cetera,
to bring together more
insightful intelligence
than you ever have before.
Lastly as we think about, you
know, the evolution of this,
it's being able to scale.
Scale as you have seasonality,
scale as you see demand.
We just had Black Friday,
Cyber Monday pass by,
and we can leverage our
agents to be able to help
scale to that productivity
as opposed to hiring
new talent to help support
this new increased workload.
And the last area is personalization.
So with these new agentic workflows,
we can personalize them at the edge.
So think about your employees.
You can personalize
responses for every employee.
From an IT person to a legal person.
You can personalize the responses
and the tasks that they're able to do,
as opposed to just leveraging, you know,
task and tools that are
built for the masses.
So some real world examples that we're
starting to see across Amazon
as we look across these new capabilities,
is one, around customer service.
So in the past it's really
been about chat assistance.
Now we're seeing us being
able to leverage agentic AI
to fully automate the customer experience.
So, you know, not only
responding to questions,
but being able to route these questions,
being able to resolve and
manage these questions
from end to end without
human intervention.
The other area is around
the way that we think about manufacturing.
You know, in many cases,
these issues would come in,
it would require multiple handoffs
to be able to resolve them.
Now we're handling about a third of these
autonomously leveraging agentic AI.
The other area's around e-commerce.
So now we're being able to bring in
more data across the web,
how our customers are
interacting with our website,
and being able to provide
things like new pricing,
new paid promotions based on the
buying patterns that
the customer is having.
And in many cases, we're able to salvage,
you know, customers who have
left items in their cart
and being able to convert those
to potential opportunities
in the future as well.
So all of these, what
we're showing is that
we're able to scale leveraging agentic AI
safely and confidently
across an organization.
And we have the tools to be able
to help you be able to do that.
So one thing that we, you know,
thought through as we were
thinking about this agentic AI journey
is that, you know, if you
think about your workday,
think about all the applications
that you touch, right?
So for me to get here today
and to create this presentation,
it took me seven different applications
and tools to get here, right?
That include my email, Outlook,
included Asana, where I
have my projects managed,
included Word, included
Quip, which we use,
included Slack, included Teams,
included a Zoom for me
to record our meetings
and record some of these demos here,
but seven different applications.
And so what does that mean, right?
You know, if you think about
your day to day, what does that mean?
It means that the average worker
has to switch between
context and applications
many different times in a day.
And what that means is that the quality
of responses are at a lower level.
The amount of time it takes
to be able to bring together information
or respond to something,
it's not optimized in
the way that it could be.
And so these are all ways that we believe
that you can accelerate
the way that you do work.
And so that's why we've
introduced Amazon Quick Suite.
So Amazon Quick Suite is really
built for the enterprise.
Connecting data sources,
connecting enterprise applications,
as well as different systems
to help you do your job.
So what I'm gonna share next is a video
in terms of this new
application that we've
just launched in October 9th.
And we will then go into some details
in terms of the capabilities
to help scale across your organization.
- [Announcer] Introducing
Amazon Quick Suite,
a revolutionary solution
that transforms how you work.
Let's say you're a marketing manager
conducting a competitive
benchmarking analysis.
Quick Suite can conduct
comprehensive research
across internal data sources
and the public internet in minutes.
It can also help you better understand
your social media campaign
data with an executive summary
that includes performance metrics,
detailed data analysis,
and messaging adjustment recommendations.
Quick Suite can also help with
automating your notifications
and even creating custom chat agents.
Such as a marketing onboarding assistant
to ensure responses are highly relevant
and specific to your team.
Give your employees Agentic AI superpowers
with Amazon Quick Suite.
- So with Amazon Quick Suite,
so just a number of different use cases
that we're leveraging
across our organization is,
you know, when we're leveraging it
across our customer service
to be able to respond to customer queries
and resolve those issues,
we're leveraging it across
our finance department
to help with invoicing.
So imagine in the past, in those days
where you had to submit
your expense report,
you had to submit your tickets,
sorry, your receipts and information
on your travels that you've done.
We can automate all of
those processes today
leveraging Amazon Quick Suite.
In addition, we're leveraging it across,
you know, several of our e-commerce sites
to be able to help automate
the way that they are
doing business as well.
So some exciting times
with Amazon Quick Suite,
I'd now like to introduce
Steve to the floor.
He'll start to talk about
some critical foundations
to be successful in this new world.
Accessing data, security,
governance, integrations, and scalability,
whether connecting to internal systems,
third party applications,
or other agents or actions.
We have the foundations
to help you connect
to enterprise, scale,
and be ready to scale these applications.
- Great, thank you Alicia.
Hey everybody, good afternoon.
So excited to talk with you today.
A little bit about Quick
Suite, how we set it up,
how we configure Quick Suite,
some of the governance that you
can have in place around it,
the security, the identity aspects of it,
how you connect your identities from your
enterprise environment into Quick Suite.
Talk about, again,
you know, guardrails and how you could
implement different guardrails,
and talk about the security
behind the scenes within
Quick Suite itself.
So quick question though,
is people familiar at
all with Quick Suite yet?
Have you tried it out?
A few of you?
A lot of you actually.
Awesome, that's great.
So, excellent.
Want to kind of jump into it,
get you a little bit information about
how we think about privacy.
And so with Quick Suite,
your data stays private.
We never use your data
for training our LLMs,
for any kind of service improvement,
for anything, AWS does
not touch your data.
Your data remains your data,
it's private within your account.
You control what you do
with your data at all times.
So we don't sell it to third parties,
we don't give it to other, you know,
parts of Amazon to analyze.
It's all kept private in your
environment, in your account.
And we encrypt it everywhere, right?
So we encrypt data at rest,
we encrypt it, data in motion,
we encrypt the network layer.
We use AWS customer managed keys
or AWS managed keys for encryption.
So you had that option as well.
And you had that flexibility to
decide how you want to encrypt your data.
On the network side,
you can deploy Quick Suite
in your account within a VPC,
you can connect to other data sources,
other AWS applications like Redshift
or Athena, or Lake Formation, or S3
within your protected AWS environment,
within your AWS accounts, within the VPC.
We also have the ability
to have IP restrictions.
So part of Quick Suite
is an admin interface,
but then there's also the web interface
where end users interact with Quick Suite.
And in both those
environments you could set up
IP restrictions to restrict access
to only the trusted IP addresses,
the IP address ranges
known as a cider range that you wanna set.
So you have really great controls
about restricting who can actually
access that data from
your trusted networks.
And then we have VPC endpoint
restrictions as well.
And so across Quick Suite,
there's a number of different capabilities
within Quick Suite itself.
It's built on the foundation
of Amazon QuickSight.
And so the namespace for all of the APIs
is the QuickSight namespace.
And currently we have VPC endpoint support
for all those QuickSight namespace APIs
at the control plane level as
well as the data plane level.
We're adding additional
VPC endpoint support
that'll cover the full
surface area of Quick Suite.
And you'll see that coming
out in the coming weeks
in the next couple months.
But certainly within the next few months
we'll have full VPC endpoint support
across all of Quick Suite.
One of the big ways to control access
within Quick Suite today is through
what we call custom permissions.
And this is the ability to,
you can set granular controls
to restrict capabilities
at the capability level.
And I'll get into that.
I'll show you some demo clips around that.
You can control it at
either the user level,
at the role level,
and I'll explain the different
roles that we have available
or at the overall account level.
And it's a hierarchy in the sense that
the user level is the most
restrictive set of permissions.
So if I have a user that's assigned
a permission at the account level
as well as at the user level,
the user level permission
will take precedent
over any account level permissions.
There's also feature level restrictions
that you can set within
Quick Suite as well.
And there's different features.
So for example, for
QuickSight functionality,
like being able to download
Excel files or PDFs,
or being able to create
data sets or data sources,
those are the finer grained permissions
that you can restrict access to,
again, based on that user
role or account level.
And all this is available with our APIs.
And so this is something
that you can automate.
So if you're thinking about
deploying Quick Suite at scale,
many of our enterprise customers deploy
across many, many AWS accounts
and have many instances
of Quick Suite deployed.
So 100s of accounts.
In some cases even 1,000s.
And so they need to be able
to manage that at scale.
And how you do that is through our APIs.
And so all the permissions that
the custom permissions that you set,
really all of our governance controls
that you can set within Quick Suite
are things that can be
set via APIs as well.
Now on the Identity and
Access Management front,
there's multiple identity options for you
to connect into Quick Suite today,
and I'll go over them a little
bit more later in a demo.
But the four main options,
so there's AWS IAM Identity Center
and Identity Center is from
a Quick Suite perspective,
you can think of it as a
service provider interface
into Quick Suite from
an identity perspective.
So you can have your
corporate or enterprise
identity provider like
Okta, Ping, Entra ID.
You connect into AWS Identity Center once,
you can skim sync your users and groups,
and that AWS Identity Center instance
can be used across all AWS applications.
And so that's an option that's available
for you in Quick Suite today.
There's also, if you have an
active directory environment,
you can directly connect Active
Directory into Quick Suite
and synchronize your users
and groups there as well.
We also have AWS IAM account
federation as an option.
So you deploy Quick Suite
into an AWS account,
you can set up IAM Federation
at that account level
and then connect your
users into Quick Suite
via IAM Federation.
Now one of the differences there is that
to manage the group access,
you set up and create groups
within Quick Suite itself.
So you get the users,
you provision them into Quick
Suite through IAM Federation
and then you assign them to
groups within Quick Suite
using the Quick Suite APIs.
And then finally you can have
local users within Quick Suite.
And so this is where you
can just simply set up
a user with a username, email,
they set a password,
and they can access Quick Suite locally
with those credentials.
Now there's different
roles within Quick Suite.
The primary roles are
really the Admin Pro,
the Author Pro, and the Reader Pro.
And this is what you would consider
the different types of entitlements
that you have within Quick Suite.
but it's also how you can assign users
and then assign custom permissions
at that role level as well.
Now, why we have pro
against each of those,
that's where the agentic AI
capabilities come into play.
And so any role that's set
with a pro designation on it
means that that user will
have access to some level
of agentic AI capabilities
within Quick Suite.
We also have some roles from
when it was just Amazon QuickSight.
Which are just the admin role,
the author role, and the reader role.
So without the pro designation on it.
And what that means is you
just have access to the base
QuickSight BI capabilities
that you would've always had if you were
just using QuickSight previously.
And from a data governance perspective,
fine grain access control
with row-level security,
column-level security,
you can audit all this information
collectively within CloudTrail.
What's great here is if
you're creating a data set
and implementing row-level
security in that data set,
then when you create a dashboard
from that data set, for example,
when that user goes to view a dashboard,
they're only seeing the data
that they're allowed to see
because you've set that fine
grain row-level security.
So that dashboard's
only gonna present data
that they're authorized to view.
And then I just wanna
touch on guardrails a bit.
And there's a couple areas where we
implement guardrails across Quick Suite.
And so there's service managed
guardrails that we implement
as part of the service, as
part of offering Quick Suite
to you as a managed capability.
And there we do real time analysis against
security policies that we set.
We automatically enforce it.
So thinking about, you
know, content coming in,
content going out,
analyzing it and making sure that
there's no potential,
you know, injected content into
a prompt that tries to kind of
circumvent the controls that
are within Quick Suite today
or within the underlying LLM
that's available within Quick Suite.
And so we take care of
that at the service level.
Then there's certain
features in Quick Suite
like Flows for example, or Automate,
where you can use your
Bedrock environment as well.
And so you can choose the model
that you want from Bedrock.
And within Bedrock,
that's where you can set
your additional guardrails as well.
So deny topics, sensitive
information, that type of stuff
that you can set as well as, you know,
filtering on certain words or phrases
within the bedrock context
of what you're using in Quick Suite.
And then there's additional
customer managed controls.
And these controls,
again, similar in some respects
to the bedrock controls you have.
So you can set like word filters
that'll filter out
certain words or phrases
that you just, that you want to add on top
of what we already do as
providing as a service.
And just to give you a kind of a view
at one of the screens around that,
so this is with a chat agent,
how you can customize
the guardrails and safety
controls around a chat agent.
And so here there's,
you know, three checks.
The prompt link injection, prompt safety,
and block words and phrases.
And so prompt link injection,
that's where it's automatically enabled.
It prevents, you know, prompt injection
and other LLM type of breaking attacks.
So again, you have, if
you have a bad actor
trying to do something that
they shouldn't be doing,
we take care of that
for you automatically.
That's why it's just kind
of checked by default.
Prompt safety as well,
you know, protect against the common
security threats that are out there.
That's something that we set again
and manage on your behalf.
And then blocked words and phrases.
This is where it's kind of,
it's a shared responsibility
model in a sense.
We take care of the vast
majority of bad content
that shouldn't be
represented in the workplace,
but you can add additional
custom words and phrases
you want to restrict that content.
Another feature or control that you have
is on clickable external links.
And so, when you chat with
an agent and it responds,
it'll also reference the
documents that it uses.
Whether it's internal
documents that you have
or documents that are
available on the web.
And you can decide if
you want those documents
that are available on the web
to be clickable links or not.
It's just another control
capability that you have
within the chat agent itself.
And so this now is gonna go through
setting up a new Quick Suite account
and just kind of walk you
through a little demo video.
I'll try to keep up with
the video as it's playing.
But I'm gonna go ahead and
sign up for Quick Suite.
And as you see I have to enter
a unique account name here.
So this is the account
name for Quick Suite.
So when you go to the Quick Suite URL,
you enter the account name
that you want to access.
And so that's the account
that you set it to.
Here I'm selecting a region
and so I select Northern Virginia.
And then there's the four
different identity options
that I talked about earlier.
In this example, I'm gonna go ahead
and use IAM Identity Center
as the identity provider
for this environment.
One thing I have to do now is go
and set up an Admin Pro group
in order to configure this correctly.
So I go ahead and search for my groups.
I see a QuickSight admin
group, I'm gonna add that in.
I could add additional
users or groups into additional
roles within Quick Suite.
I could do it here or I could do it later.
I chose, I'm gonna do it later.
And then here's also where
you set the encryption, right?
So you can use an AWS managed key
or your own custom managed key.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and create that account,
I'll click on it and it starts creating.
Just takes a couple seconds to do that.
And so you have one Quick Suite account
that you create per AWS account.
So account created successfully.
I can either go directly
into Quick Suite now
and start working within Quick Suite
or I can go and do additional
management configuration.
I'm gonna go ahead and do some
additional management
configuration of this environment.
And now it takes me to the
main management account page.
And so up top what you'll see is,
it says that I'm signed
in with IAM Permissions.
And this is,
so when you set it up
you have to have the right
IAM Permissions, right?
So you have to be able to create
the instance of Quick Suite,
but then there's also certain
administrative functions
within Quick Suite
that require IAM permissions as well.
There's other functions that require
the Admin Pro group that
we referenced earlier
to function.
So just to give you a quick
view of what that looks like.
Basically the high level
account type level settings
are things that require
IAM level permissions.
So you really use these level
permissions very rarely.
For the most part you're going to be
using an admin role permission.
So that's a user within Quick Suite itself
to do more of the day-to-day type of
management or administrative functions
that you would within Quick Suite, right?
So you know, managing users,
any type of account customizations,
managing subscriptions,
that type of information
that you want to do, you
would do that through
just a regular Quick Suite admin user.
Now I wanna take you through some more
of the account settings.
So now I'm in the AWS Management console.
I'm gonna go ahead and
click on Quick Suite,
log back into the account
that I just created,
and I'm gonna talk first about
some of the account settings
that are in the top left.
So you'll see account settings,
manage assets, and Amazon Q.
I'm showing this account settings once,
you don't want to go there very often.
We have some protection there in place
so you don't accidentally
delete the account,
but that's where you would
go to delete the account.
The manage assets function,
this is a really powerful tool
because I can search by user
and see what assets are
assigned to that user.
I can then go in and reassign
those assets to someone else.
I could share it with someone else
or I could remove that user's access
to that particular asset.
Another nice feature is that I
can search by the asset type.
So I can go ahead and look at flows
and it'll pull up all the flows
that are active in my account
and I can go there and share those flows
across with different users.
Now, Amazon Q in Quick Suite,
those are account level settings
for the Amazon Q features
that were available in just QuickSight.
And so these are our
agentic AI capabilities
to be able to interact with dashboards,
interact with data sets, ask questions,
ask kind of Q and A type information
and use agentic AI to get
responses back based on that data.
So you can ask natural
language query questions
and get back answers based on the data
that it's referencing.
Next one I wanna walk you through
is setting custom permissions.
And so here you'll see,
you know, I clicked on managed positions.
I have two profiles set.
One the default and it says account.
And so I've set that default
profile at the account level,
meaning that any user in that account
is gonna have that default
profile associated with them.
But when you look at it,
when I click in there,
anything that's unchecked
means that it's available.
So the way permissions work
is that you check it to restrict it.
So if I wanted to restrict
research or restrict analysis
and QuickSight or restrict flows,
I would check that box,
and then the users that
that profile is assigned to
would not be able to use those features.
So you can see here when
I, the next one down,
I had restrict spaces.
So what I'll do here is I'm
signed in as a different user.
You can see I have all those
different capabilities listed there.
Agents, Spaces, Flows, and Research.
I can interact with spaces,
I can, you know, create a space if I want,
set it up, I can share that space.
I can basically do anything
I want in that space
because I'm not restricted
from using that right now.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
create a new space, save it,
and you can see that saved.
And then if I wanted to share
it, I could share it out.
I could add additional data to it.
Whether it's data sets.
And now I could go back and
see I have access to that.
So this is the the next user
and they can see that they have access
to the spaces as well.
So what I'm gonna go ahead and do
is go back into my custom permissions,
and now instead of having the
default at the account level,
I'm gonna switch it to Restrict Spaces as
the default profile.
And it's asking me to confirm that
because it's an important request.
I wanna make sure that this
is what you want to do.
The effects happened pretty immediately
and so that's why you ask for it.
But you can easily remove
it and change it back.
It doesn't remove any data
that you have access to.
So now I'm back looking at this user.
I see they still have spaces,
but when they click on it I
get the error in the top right.
So in near real time
I've disabled that functionality
or restricted that
functionality for that user.
And you'll see it still has,
excuse me, spaces listed
on the top left in the nav bar.
So I went ahead and signed out,
I'm gonna go back and
signed back in again.
And when I sign back in,
you'll see that spaces
option in the nav bar
is no longer available either.
So just by simply restricting spaces,
restricting it and applying
it at the account level,
this user's now not able to
access that space anymore.
I can go ahead and switch
it back to the default,
go back to that user again,
this time just gonna refresh.
It takes a couple seconds
to refresh the UI,
but in a couple seconds you'll see,
I think it took three refreshes here,
but in a couple seconds you'll see
that now spaces will be available again.
And so it happens that fast.
Again, they didn't lose any assets
that they previously had access to.
It was just a configuration change
that restricted what they
could do going forward.
You'll also see then there's
feature level restrictions
you can set across Quick
Suite and QuickSight
and it gets fairly granular.
And you'll see as we add additional
capabilities within Quick Suite,
we'll be adding additional
custom permissions.
So you can decide how you best wanna roll
Quick Suite out in your
organization, right?
You may say, "Oh I want research agent
to be available to this group of users."
And you can say, "But they
don't need anything else.
Maybe they need Chat Research Agent
and then Core BI capabilities."
So you can go in and set a policy
that restricts all the other
capabilities except for those,
assign those users to that new policy
and all they see is
the research agent chat
and any of the BI capabilities
that you want to give them.
As granular as well,
so being able to, like
I mentioned earlier,
being able to export data,
you can control if they're
allowed to export data or not.
Again, this is something that can be
applied at the user
level, at the role level,
or at the account level.
So this is one now, how
do we do this at scale?
So let's say we have,
again 100s of accounts,
you're not gonna go into the UI every time
and try every account
and manage that at scale.
So you can do this via API.
I decided to use Kiro CLI,
I don't know if anyone's used Kiro yet,
but awesome product.
And I'm just gonna ask Kiro
to create a policy for me,
set it up, restrict access,
and then assign it to a user.
So let's see how it does.
So we can see I am logged
in as Daphne this time.
I have access to all the capabilities
within Quick Suite today,
But I wanna restrict some of
of Daphne's permissions.
Right now you see there's the two profiles
that I had previously set.
I don't have any set at
the account level yet.
So Daphne has full access
to all of Quick Suite.
So what I wanna do is ask Kiro in the CLI
to create this new policy for me.
So simply ask Kiro in natural language
to create a policy,
restrict certain features
and then assign it to a user.
So Kiro's gonna go in,
figure all that out,
run the APIs in order to make that happen,
and then come back and let
me know that it's complete.
So there it's going through the process.
You can see it's putting deny filters
on things like flows and research,
and it's showing
that it is now successfully
assigned that to the user, Daphne.
And I also created this profile called
CLI_restrictions.
So if I go ahead and refresh this page,
I'll see that new profile set up.
You'll see in the restricts
it shows agents, flows,
research, and spaces.
Those are the things that
I asked it to restrict.
And now I'm gonna go
ahead and sign Daphne out
and back in again.
And when I do that, we'll see what happens
as far as the left Nav goes.
So now all those
capabilities were restricted
so this user no longer has access
to any of those capabilities.
Another great feature,
especially as you're
rolling Quick Suite out,
and how do you manage it at scale
and how do you know are
users actually using it?
You certainly can look in
CloudTrail and figure it out.
It gets a little complex to do when you're
trying to look at all the different events
that'll show up in CloudTrail.
But what we've done is built some
internal usage analytics
for you to get a view on
how well are certain things,
you know, being used within
your Quick Suite environment.
So you can look at like daily,
weekly, or monthly active users.
How often are users coming back
and using Quick Suite again and again?
You can look at the different features
that are available in Quick Suite
and you can see how often
are they using them again.
You can also look at certain like,
so users that have the
ability to create agents,
you can have many agents
in your organization,
but you wanna see which ones
are actually being used.
This analysis will give
you that information,
it'll let you know very easily
what are the popular agents
that people keep going back to.
And that gives you an
insight into figuring out
how do you, can you replicate those?
Maybe it's really good
prompting around it,
maybe it's just the way
that it's configured
that just meets a specific
business case or use case
and that's what's driving
the adoption for it.
So as we kind of think about
deploying Quick Suite at scale,
yeah, we talked about
streamlining user provisioning
to reduce administrative overhead.
And when I talked about
those four different
identity options earlier,
things like using Identity Center
allows you to use your
corporate identity provider,
sync users in groups into Identity center,
and make those users in groups
available in Quick Suite.
So a change in your
upstream identity provider
like Okta or Ping
is immediately synchronized
into Identity Center,
which then immediately
synchronizes back into Quick Suite.
So what that means is that if you revoke
a user from a group membership
or add users to a group,
that user gets propagated
down all the way.
So they do have access to Quick Suite
if that's what that group has access to.
We have really strong
governance capabilities
through custom permissions
that we just saw some demos on.
But also, again, being able to
manage at a really granular level
who has access to the data.
So we talked a little bit
about row-level security,
column-level security on data sets
that are created with structured data.
And this is from data that's created,
whether it's an AWS application
like Redshift or Athena,
or even S3, or if it's a third party
application like Snowflake
for example, or Databricks,
you can still ingest that
information, that data,
as a data set
and you can assign row-level
and column-level security to it.
So you can get that fine
grain access control
on that as well.
And the other part within Quick Suite
is, so that's the, what
we call structured data,
your database data.
That's well, you know, well managed.
Then you have what we
call unstructured data
or knowledge-based type data.
So this is your SharePoint data.
This could be just a bunch of PDF files
or something that are
uploaded to an S3 bucket,
but you want to be able to
manage access to those, right?
So you want to ingest it because
there's useful information
about your organization
that you want to be able
to take and have quick suite reference
and help provide answers against,
but you also want to control
access to that as well.
And so you're able to ingest
the ACLs with that information.
So the responses that come back
are only responses that
that user's authorized to see, right?
So it looks and sees who that,
what that user has access to,
it crafts a response based
on that user's access
and it only presents the information
that they're allowed to see.
There's a scalable security architecture.
You know, we talked about,
again, the identity aspect of it,
we talked about managing
permissions via API
and all this, you know,
all the security controls you
can implement through APIs.
So you can scale this
out across many accounts.
And that's how you can do like
the lifecycle management as well, right?
So you can script it,
you can put it into your
operational procedures.
And so as users, as you
give kind of permissions out
for users to create their
own Quick Suite account,
you can immediately put custom permissions
on the creation of that account
so they can only access the features
that you want them to access.
So you have the centralized
governance capability,
but you can also
decentralize the ability for
departments or teams to be able
to spin up their own
instance of Quick Suite,
make their own connections,
create their own dashboards,
create their own agents.
But you can still have that
central governance over the top.
So with that, I'm gonna hand it back.
Okay.
Alicia, thank you.
- So we've talked quite a bit about
how within Amazon we've built
and managed this application.
We have a number of customers that are
presenting throughout re:Invent.
This morning we had 3M present
in terms of how they've reimagined
their sales and marketing organization,
leveraging Quick Suite.
Also earlier this morning we heard
from AstraZeneca as well as BMW
in terms of how they've scaled
this across their organizations as well.
Later this week we'll hear from JABIL
in terms of how they're creating
their workflow automation step by step
in terms of how they're reimagining,
how they're doing work from
a manufacturing perspective.
Principal Financial
will also be presenting
in terms of how they're leveraging
the research aspects of Amazon Quick Suite
to be able to help deliver better
responses to their customers.
And then a number of different use cases
will be on our business intelligence
as well as embedding capabilities
across our financial and
application providers.
So please look out for those.
We have a list of different
sessions throughout the week.
We have one session today at 5:30
if you're still interested to learn more.
It's about our embedding capabilities
within Amazon Quick Suite
where you can really
think about, you know,
how you can leverage it beyond the UI
and really embed into the applications
that you're working within.
In addition, on Tuesday we
have a number of chalk talks.
So this is a breakout
session where you hear about
specific use cases in a chalk talk.
We'll start to go into more
of a whiteboarding session
and go into some details, Q and A,
for you to dive deeper in terms
of the capabilities within Quick Suite.
And then we also have workshops as well.
So if you want hands on keyboard,
really be able to create
these different flows,
automations, agents,
we have a number of different sessions
that you can go to as well.
So these are some other sessions
on Wednesday and Thursday,
but throughout this
whole session there are
many different areas for you to be able
to learn more about the session.
In addition, we'll also
be in the AWS Village.
So we have a booth, A-9 through A-10.
You can also leverage
Amazon Quick Suite there
if you haven't already gotten access.
We have ourselves, Steve, myself,
will be around as well
as a number of our essays
and sales and marketing organization
to help answer any
questions that you may have.
So thank you so much for your time.
We are really excited for you
to spend the the last 45 minutes with us.
I'm happy to answer any questions
or follow-ups after this session,
or please meet us in
the booth to learn more.
Thank you so much.